so ich würde ich mich auch ein bisschen
bewegen nicht dass ich ja dass
wer meine damen und herren wir sind sie
sehr herzlich zu pressebriefing im
robert-koch-institut am 17 april 2020
heute wieder mit professor lothar wieler
präsident des robert koch instituts wie
üblich zuerst das eingangs statement und
danach folgen die fragen der
medienvertreter hätte ja bitte guten
morgen meine damen und herren lassen
nämlich zunächst einen kurzen überblick
über die kurve 19 lage in der welt geben
die quelle ist das europäische zentrum
für krankheitskontrolle das icd sie die
daten sind vom 6 14 10 uhr
weltweit sind insbesondere folgende
länder betroffen
die vereinigten staaten hier haben wir
rund 340.000 fälle spanien rund 131.000
fälle und italien rund 129.000 fälle und
wir haben dort in italien inzwischen
rund 15.800 todesfälle gemeldet
mittlerweile sind weltweit mehr als eine
million menschen befallen also offiziell
gemeldete fallzahlen und nahezu alle
länder sind betroffen besonders aktiv
ist das ausbruchsgeschehen im moment in
nordamerika und europa die ausführlichen
fallzahl finden sie wie immer auf den
seiten der weltgesundheitsorganisation
der whu und dc dc und die sind ja auch
auf unserer cupid 19 seite verlinkt das
geschehen ist weiterhin sehr dynamisch
und wir haben immer noch zunehmenden
fallzahlen aber sie interessiert
natürlich vor allem die situation in
deutschland wie sieht das aus die daten
die ich ihnen vorstelle sind vom 17 40
uhr und zu diesem zeitpunkt wurden
offiziell gemeldet 99 1225 kurve 19
fälle das sind 3834 mehr als am vortag
unter diesen fällen waren 1600 sieben
todesfälle gemeldet das sind 173 mehr
als am vortag
die gesamt inzidenz betrug zu diesem
zeitpunkt 119 fälle pro 100.000
einwohner
und wie in den vergangenen wochen
ebenfalls variiert sie stark
deutschlandweit nur ein beispiel in
bayern haben wir momentan 200 fälle pro
100.000 einwohner in mecklenburg
vorpommern beträgt diese zahl 33
aktuell schätzen wir die zahl der
chinesen in deutschland auf 33.300 das
ist eine erfreuliche zahl die anzahl der
neu übermittelten fälle ist etwas
geringer
von einer entspannung kann aber noch
nicht ausgegangen werden schwankungen
sind immer möglich das bitte ich sie zu
beachten
wir müssen die nächsten tage abwarten ob
sich bei den meldungen ein trend
abzeichnet wir aktualisieren die
fallzahlen also die offiziell gemeldeten
fallzahlen jeden tag sie können sie ganz
detailliert auf unserem dashboard
einsehen dass unter corona punkt ag.de
für jedermann zugänglich ist
auch möchte ich noch mal darauf
hinweisen dass hier täglich einen
situationsbericht auf unserer website
publizieren wo wir eine lage
einschätzung geben auch den finden sie
eben unter der kontakten website
krone.at punkt.de auch der ist für jeden
einsehbar und jeden tag wollte
aktualisiert allerdings erst immer
nachmittags ist nicht um 0 uhr also
nicht um mitternacht
betrachten wir ein wenig die einzelnen
fälle in deutschland was wissen wir
anhand der offiziell gemeldeten
information über die kogit 19 fälle in
deutschland
die betroffenen personen sind im
durchschnitt 48 jahre alt männer und
frauen sind gleich betroffen momentan
für rund 74.000 übermittelte fälle
liegen uns klinische informationen vor
die häufigsten symptome die genannt
werden sind husten bei 52 prozent der
gemeldeten fälle fieber bei 42 prozent
und schnupfen bei 22 prozent
für zwei prozent der übermittelten fälle
das sind alle rund 1700 ist bekannt dass
sie eine ente lungenentzündung
entwickelt haben
und für rund 74.000 fälle liegen
informationen zur hospitalisierung vor
bei rund 10.700 fällen wurde eine
hospitalisierung übermittelt und das
sind rund 14 prozent was wissen wir über
die bislang in deutschland im rahmen der
kogit 19 waren die hmi verstorbenen
personen sind wie ich sagte 1607 und das
sind mehr 173 mehr als wir das gestern
gesehen haben unseren zahlen
momentan beträgt der anteil der
verstorbenen unter allen gemeldeten
fällen 1,6 prozent die zahl der
todesfälle und der anteil der
verstorbenen ist in den letzten tagen
kontinuierlich gestiegen das ist zum
einen auf eine zunahme von ausbrüchen in
alters und pflegeheimen sowie in
krankenhäusern zurückzuführen wo
besonders risikogruppen natürlich
betroffen sind
zum anderen sehen wir jetzt generell
immer mehr erkrankungsfälle bei älteren
menschen
das ist ein geschehen das wir leider so
erwarten mussten die todesfälle die
jetzt auftreten betreffen menschen die
vor ein bis zwei wochen erkrankt sind
das heißt also es befinden sich auch
noch viele kurven 19 fälle in
stationärer behandlung und daher ist mit
einem weiteren anstieg der todesfälle zu
rechnen
die verstorbene person waren im
durchschnitt 80 jahre alt und unter den
verstorbenen waren rund 1400 personen 70
jahre und älter
die bislang jüngste verstorbene person
war 28 jahre alt und sie litt an
vorerkrankungen
das ist die lage einschätzung vom
heutigen tag dem siebten april
und ich möchte mich jetzt zu einem thema
widmen das für das robert koch institut
und für die bekämpfung der kurve 19
pandemie sicher eine wichtige rolle
spielt zumindest einer ein ein wichtiger
baustein
gesamten bekämpfungsstrategie die wir
sehr konsequent und systematisch von
anfang an führen
im moment wird sehr viel darüber
nachgedacht wie digitale anwendungen
dabei helfen können cupid 19 einzudämmen
um das krankheitsgeschehen zu bewerten
reichen ja die offiziellen meldezahlen
die ich ihnen auch soeben wieder
vorgestellt habe alleine nicht aus
deshalb hat das robert koch institut in
den letzten jahren mehrere zusätzliche
werkzeuge entwickelt um die krankheit
schwere von atemwegserkrankungen besser
messen zu können
senden sie uns zum beispiel ambulante
praxen proben ein in denen wir das
vorkommen von viren nachweisen
seit kurzem eben auch von saas und koch
zwei viren aber wir erhalten auch
informationen über schwere verläufe von
lungenentzündungen aus krankenhäusern
mit einem digitalen werkzeug das hat den
namen eco sari ein weiteres digitales
tool dass wir schon seit mehreren jahren
führen ist grippe web dort geben mehrere
tausend mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger
symptome ein
die uns einen weiteren einblick in das
krankheitsgeschehen in deutschland
übermitteln
aber heute möchte ich ihnen eine weitere
app vorstellen eine neue web de
entwickelt wurde in den letzten wochen
das ist die korona daten spende app mit
dieser app kann man freiwillig dem
robert-koch-institut bestimmte daten zur
verfügung stellen und somit dabei helfen
noch besser einzuschätzen wo und auch
wie schnell sich kurve 19 in deutschland
verbreitet was man dafür braucht ist
eine smart watch oder ein fitness
armband und eben die korona daten spende
app die es kostenlos zum download gibt
und zwar ab heute was ist die idee
hinter dieser app lassen nämlich dass
kurz erläutern
viele menschen in deutschland zeichnen
mit ihrem smart watch oder fitness
armbändern ihre vitaldaten auf zum
beispiel den ruhepuls das
schlafverhalten oder das
aktivitätsniveau bei einer akuten
atemwegserkrankung ändern sich diese
vitalzeichen natürlich deutlich und
meistens sehr deutlich sogar bei einer
akuten atemwegserkrankung ist es so dass
kurve 19 symptome erkannt werden können
allen voran ist das fieber aber auch
weniger aktivität auch ein verändertes
schlaf mit hilfe der app die wir
entwickelt haben wird also die
verbreitung von bestimmten symptomen
erfasst
wenn man eine ausreichend große
stichprobe hat und noch weitere daten
hinzu zieht zum beispiel die meldedaten
zu kurve 19 die ich ihn eben vorstellte
dann können unsere wissenschaftler
daraus zusätzlich rückschlüsse über die
verbreitung von coop 19 10
ein ähnliches produkt hat bereits in den
vereinigten staaten gezeigt dass mit
diesen daten zb grippewellen sehr gut
abgebildet werden können
ich möchte aber noch mal betonen ganz
wichtig zu verstehen ist dass diese app
symptome erkennt das ist keine app die
einen coup 19 nachweis führen kann die
app ersetzt also keine tests und sie
warnt den nutzer auch nicht dass er
krank sein könnte
die app ersetzt auch keine offiziellen
meldezahlen sie ist einfach nur eine
ergänzung aber aus unserer sicht eine
sehr wichtige ergänzung
wie funktioniert die app genommen
über die app stellen uns nutzer folgende
daten freiwillig zur verfügung die
postleitzahl körperdaten wie das
geschlecht alter größe und gewicht und
einige vitaldaten wie aktivitäts und
schlaf daten pulsschlag teils auch
körpertemperatur falls das gerät das man
trägt in der lage ist dies zu erfassen
diese daten werden dann bei uns
wissenschaftlich aufbereitet und fließen
zusammen mit den anderen daten den ich
ihm vorher genannt hatte in eine
interaktive karte und diese zeigt die
regionale verbreitung von potenziell
infizierten bis auf ebene der
postleitzahl
die karte wird dann im internet
veröffentlicht und regelmäßig
aktualisiert so bekommen unsere
wissenschaftler ein präziseres bild zum
beispiel über bestimmte
infektionsgeschehen und vor allen dingen
natürlich auch ein einblick darüber ob
die maßnahmen die wir seit einigen
wochen fahren greifen
die app wurde vom robert koch institut
gemeinsam mit einem unternehmen für
ehealth entwickelt natürlich ist die
teilnahme freiwillig die daten sind
pseudonymisiert das heißt das
robert-koch-institut hat keine kenntnis
über den namen und die anschrift des
nutzers es werden auch keine mobilfunk
oder ortungsdaten erfasst das speichern
und das verarbeiten der daten erfolgt
selbstverständlich streng nach den
vorgaben der europäischen datenschutz
grund worten meine damen und herren ich
bin fest davon überzeugt dass digitale
anwendungen ein sinnvolle ergänzung ist
zu den bisherigen maßnahmen wir und ich
wir wünschen uns dass sie viele menschen
diese corona daten spende app
herunterladen und mitmachen
das heißt also dass wir zusammenarbeiten
dass wissenschaftler und bürger hier
zusammenarbeiten sich aktiv beteiligen
und uns damit die chance geben die
bekämpfung von coop 19 strategisch noch
besser durchführen zu können und
effektive
klar ist dass je mehr der menschen ihre
daten zur verfügung stellen desto
genauer werden wir eben erkenntnisse
über die verbreitung des corona virus
haben die apps für ios und auch
android-geräte verfügbar
und wie schon sagte man kann sie jetzt
in den entsprechenden stores
herunterladen noch mal den namen der
apogee heißt corona daten spende ja und
mehr informationen und antworten auf
häufig gestellte fragen finden sie unter
www corona - daten spende punkt.de danke
ihnen für ihre aufmerksamkeit
vielen dank herr wieder noch kurz paar
wenige organisatorische hinweise
erstmals haben wir jetzt heute die
möglichkeit dass die medienvertreter
live die fragen stellen können mit audio
es hat leider moment gedauert
datenschutzrechtlich konformes system
aufzubauen
wir hatten darüber auch alle am späten
nachmittag informiert in unserem
medienverteiler das heißt schriftlich
übermittelte fragen können wir jetzt
nicht mehr übermittelt werden wir haben
die entsprechenden medienvertreter aber
gebeten sich dann auch einzuwählen noch
den hinweis wenn sie eine frage stellen
wollen müssen sie das symbol für das
hand heben anklicken das ist relativ
klein rechts unten in diesem system zu
finden und dann kann ich entsprechend
frei schalten so dass sie dann ihre
fragen stellen können und dann würden
wir jetzt auch beginnen mit dem
handelsblatt und ich hoffe sie sind
jetzt auf sendung hätte sich ja wehren
sie hallo christa er war zum
handelsblatt sie waren bisher ja die
absolute zahl der neu infizierten
personen aus in ihrem dashboard jeden
tag es ist auch möglich die
revolutionszeit auszuweisen und können
sie angeben wie hoch die derzeit ist und
wie sich in den letzten tagen und wochen
entwickelt hat ja es gibt ja
verschiedene berechnungsmethoden für r 0
so dass sie auch teilweise bei anderen
quellen bestimmt auch etwas
differierende zahlen finden werden
es ist eine sehr schöne entwicklung dass
man in den letzten wochen insbesondere
ein rückgang von r 0 dieser re
produktionszahl gesehen hat momentan
liegt sie meines wissens im bereich
zwischen 1,2 und 1,5
das heißt sie liegt etwas höher als sie
in der letzten woche war in letzten
wochenende das sind immer
momentaufnahmen und das heißt also ich
muss immer wieder darauf hinweisen dass
wirklich alle sich an diese
abstandsregeln halten wir schauen wie
sich das weiterentwickelt wir haben das
jeden tag im blick
und das ist wirklich regelmäßig können
sie die frage noch mal gerade
wiederholen ich habe sie versehentlich
stumm geschaltet fahren
natürlich ist es auch möglich diese zahl
regelmäßig im dashboard auszuweisen weil
die wird er nach ansicht aller experten
ist die viel relevanter als die zahl der
absoluten neuinfizierten pro tag
sie haben vollkommen recht das ist eine
zahl die ich sehr relevant für uns und
wir mehr über wir werden also sie
zeichnen sie auf jeden fall in unseren
situations berichten regelmäßig aus wald
und wahrscheinlich auch im dashboard
aber das ist auch eine wie gesagt eine
elektronische problematisch da muss man
wieder etwas neu programmieren dass der
sport ist bei sw kostet aber wir wir
überlegen dass wir müssen das aber sehr
gut erklären wie gesagt es gibt eben
verschiedene berechnungsmethoden und
wenn man etwas berechnet dann sind das
ja immer berechnungen die auch in die
vergangenheit schauen und die mit
bestimmten unsicherheitsfaktoren belegt
sind aber wir werden das in zukunft
ausweisen ja das gibt mir noch die
gelegenheit zu sagen dass wir das
mikrofon so lange offen lassen dass klar
ist die frage auch sozusagen richtig
beantwortet ist also eine nachfrage ist
jeweils möglich jetzt haben wir die ard
tagesschau verhindert
hören sie mich die wissenschaftsakademie
leopoldina die hat ja am freitag einige
kriterien für einen exit szenario
veröffentlicht unter anderem mundschutz
tragen in der öffentlichkeit die
handy-app oder flächendeckende oder
weitere tests wieder empfohlen werden
wie stehen sie zu diesen maßnahmen
ergänzenden maßnahmen und wie und wann
könnte oder sollte man diese umsetzen
ja es ist richtig dass sehr viele
wissenschaftler auch vor allen dingen
auch aus verschiedenen regionen also
nicht nur biowissenschaft natürlich auch
ökonomen sozialwissenschaften sich
gedanken machen wie man die maßnahmen
die wir zurzeit im land haben vielleicht
schrittweise wieder eröffnet
das was dort steht sind alles sinnvolle
maßnahmen das sind alles maßnahmen die
ja auch in unserem paket der maßnahmen
die wir seit einigen wochen empfehlen
vorhanden sind
weil sie noch mal explizit nachfragen
ich bevorzuge eigentlich von einer
übergangsphase zu sprechen als von einem
exit strategie weil ich eigentlich davon
ausgeht dass wir schrittweise bestimmte
maßnahmen reduzieren
also das ist auch eine frage der
erwartungshaltung
bezogen auf die masken ist es so dass
wir hier in der letzten woche hatte ich
ja glaube ich ja es war am freitag hatte
ich ja sehr klar das statement des
robert koch instituts zu masken tragen
noch mal vorgetragen und das ist auch
wichtig wir müssen drei arten von masten
unterscheiden wir haben zum einen die
masken die wirklich einen selber
schützen davor dass man angesteckt wird
das sind ffp 2 oder fp3 masken und das
sind masken die wirklich medizinern
medizinischem fachpersonal vorbehalten
sein sollten weil die ja die patienten
betreuen und versorgen und das ist ja
nun mal ganz ganz wichtig dass sich
dieses personal nicht ansteckt dann
haben wir die sogenannten op masken die
auch chirurgische masken genannt werden
die vermitteln einen ganz guten schutz
für andere das heißt also wenn einer
selber infiziert ist die jemand selber
infiziert ist und dann spricht hustet
oder auch sinkt also singen ist zb
tatsächlich so dass beim singen sehr
viele tröpfchen entstehen und dann also
tröpfchen relativ weit in den raum
fliegen können dann schützt derjenige
andere davor zu einem gewissen
prozentsatz also ist er es gibt einen
gewissen schutz dafür dass andere
angesteckt werden
aber diese dritte art von masken über
die jetzt einmal mehr gesprochen wird
wir haben noch keinen griffigen namen
dafür manche nennen die community mars
oder auch textil masken die schützen
auch zu einem gewissen grad
wahrscheinlich da gibt es aber nicht
genügend
wissenschaftliche daten rüber aber die
schützen zu einem gewissen maß
wahrscheinlich auch andere das heißt
also dass die tröpfchen eben nicht so
weit fliegen aber was uns allen sehr
wichtig ist
das ist auch das gilt für alle public
health institut dafür auch für die whu
was uns allen sehr wichtig ist dieser
zusätzliche masken schulz textil schuhe
wirklich nur eine zusätzliche maßnahme
er darf nicht dazu führen dass menschen
sich in falscher sicherheit wiegen und
die anderen maßnahmen also gerade das
abstandhalten die hygiene
das sind die zentral wichtigen maßnahmen
die müssen beibehalten werden also um es
noch mal ganz kurz zu sagen diese
leopoldina statement ist natürlich geht
in die richtige richtung ist umfasst die
maßnahmen die wir auch schon seit wochen
propagieren und wie immer das heissen
wird übergangs szenario oder wie auch
immer das wird sich in den nächsten
tagen zeigen lassen sie uns wie gesagt
alle die daten die uns zur verfügung
stehen auswerten um zu sehen was dann
nach dem zwanzigsten april geschieht
vielen dank und noch eine nachfolge ich
bin nicht glücklich dass diese
technische lösung funktioniert nutzen
sie auch falcos dpa ja guten morgen herr
wieder ich musste ganz gerne wie sich
die verdopplung zeit im moment für
deutschland mit 7 lässt sich in der
politik jetzt viel diskutiert worden
können sie sich noch mal aktuellen stand
ja die verdopplung zeit ist eine
eigentliche macht wenn man von einem
exponentiellen wachstums steht
beschreibt das glaube ich ganz gut wie
rasch sich die zahlen entwickeln
momentan weiß ich nicht genau wie sie
ist muss ehrlich sagen wir sind
eigentlich mehr interessiert an dem
erneut also an der isar
reproduktionsrate halten wir für einen
relevanten faktor und der liegt meines
wissens zur zeit zwischen 1,2 und 1,5
aber heute tagesaktuell habe ich die
berechnung noch nicht gesehen das zdf
morgenmagazin
dann können sie auch mich haben aber
auch noch mal eine frage zur
aussagekraft der zahlen und steht ja
hier und da mal was in den
die situation berichten zum beispiel im
dritten viertel das wie intensiv
register mal skizziert mit der situation
in krankenhäusern aber da auch mal und
zwar einmal glaube ich erst dass die
zahl der positiven testungen und sie
sagen ja selber die meldezahlen haben
sich reicht nicht auch mal ins
verhältnis gesetzt anzahl der mutmaßlich
aussagekräftiger ist aber ich habe dazu
folgende frage bin ich noch offensiver
mit diesen mutmaßlich aussagekräftigeren
zahlen umgehen also positiv test im
verhältnis zur test anzahl warum die
nicht repräsentative studien stärker
fördern um die dunkelziffer
näherzukommen und dritte auch zu einem
klaren dritten vierten oder
veröffentlicht ein abrupter rückgang an
akuten arten das bedeutet also sie haben
vollkommen recht
wir wir müssen gute epidemiologische
studien durchführen das tun wir auch ich
nenne mal drei studien die wir momentan
starten am robert koch institut
oder sagen wir nicht am sondern also die
die wir koordinieren mit anderen
partnern zusammen das sind große studien
das sind auch anspruchsvolle studien die
müssen gut geplant sein
denn wenn sie wirklich repräsentative
daten haben wollen oder wenn sie
hinterher behaupten wollen dass die
repräsentativ sind dann brauchen sie ein
gutes studiendesign und natürlich muss
das auch entsprechend datenschutzkonform
sein und mit einer ethik wohnung
vorsehen
wir machen geplante zeit drei studien
eine studie ist eine studie die wir mit
blutspenden planen
das heißt der titel werden eindruck
darin und da geht es um antikörper
nachweisen also indirekt erregernachweis
da geht es darum zu sehen wie viel von
den blutspendern eventuell antikörper
gegen solche erreger haben dann haben
wir einen gewissen einblick in das
vorkommen der krankheit aber und das ist
keine repräsentative studie eine zweite
studie die wir planen da wissen wir
nicht genau wie viele orte das machen
das ist eine studie ähnlich der studie
die in heinsberg zurzeit von professor
strikt durchgeführt wird
wir gehen in andere ausbruchsort hinein
und schauen da die dynamik an
es ist ja sehr wichtig solche
informationen zu erhalten aber man muss
natürlich immer wissen dass jeder
ausbruch seine eigene dynamik
seine eigene geschichte das heißt dieser
ausbau situation sie eben nicht
repräsentativ aber je mehr solcher
studien für durchführen desto mehr
lernen wir natürlich über die
verbreitungsgeschwindigkeit und desto
mehr sehen wir natürlich auch wie die
interventionsmaßnahmen die von den
jeweiligen gesundheitsämter durchgeführt
werden
wie stark die greifen oder nicht greift
da kann man eine menge daraus lernen und
das dritte ist tatsächlich eine
repräsentative studie die eine große
deutschlandweite repräsentative studie
die wir ebenfalls starten werden aber
mit vielen partner zusammen und da
müssen wir eben schauen was da rauskommt
diese studien haben natürlich alle einen
bestimmten nachteil sie sind immer
momentaufnahmen das heißt also wir geben
immer einen bestimmten zeitpunkt wieder
und wir müssen bei all unseren
überlegungen das immer im kopf haben und
das ist nicht so einfach das zu erklären
wenn man einen momentan ergebnis hat er
sehen sie bei der ganzen bericht lage
immer je nachdem welche zahlen man
verwendet werden die auch
missinterpretiert
sie fragen zu den tests bezogen auf die
direkten nachweis also pcs ja natürlich
sind wir daran interessiert dass wir
möglichst in echtzeit die daten der
labore bekommen das ist momentan aber
nicht möglich technisch ist das so nicht
es gibt auch gesetzliche vorgaben wie
man an solche daten kommen wir arbeiten
da auch an technischen lösungen dass das
funktioniert kann ich aber noch nicht
versprechen aber noch mal die frage ist
berechtigt je mehr informationen wie
erhalten und hier früher wie sie
erhalten desto besser können wir
natürlich echtzeit daten auswerten und
desto weniger sind wir auf
modellierungen angewiesen das ist ein
ganz wichtiger punkt aber in dem
zusammenhang auch noch mal wenn wir zum
beispiel in deutschland eine
elektronische patientenakte hätten dann
hätte man natürlich auch sehr sehr viele
daten wir haben halt viele dieser
werkzeuge nicht und müssen für opel mit
bestimmten anderen mitteln zu helfen
vielen dank reuters erwartet
ja ich habe noch mal eine frage zum
thema genießen und deren anzahl was sie
zur erwähnten können sie sagen die
ungefähr durchschnittlich jetzt.de pro
tag die zahl der gelesenen ist und
eigentlich müsste sie ja jetzt auch
steigen also weiter steigen im
tagesdurchschnitt dann nochmal erneut
ein feld auch im zusammenhang mit den
weg ja tut mir leid die zahl habe ich
nicht im kopf aber sie haben natürlich
recht dass die zahl der gelesenen
steigen muss das ist klar solange die
zahl der infizierten steigt und wir
wissen ja dass eben der geringere teil
der infizierten schwer krank wird bzw
auch verstirbt wird natürlich die zahl
der chinesen auf spannung aber ich kann
dazu keine zahlen sagen aber das ist
eine logische logische fortgang die id
tagesthemen herr hahn
frau hahn gibt es pläne für
sonderregelungen für risikogruppen für
den fall dass diese einschränkenden
maßnahmen gelockert werden wenn sie auf
unsere website gehen dort haben wir
schon seit längerem bestimmte
empfehlungen erstellt wie mit bestimmten
variablen gruppen umzugehen ist diese
empfehlung werden kontinuierlich
überarbeitet
das ist ja auch work in progress das ist
klar ich wiederhole es gerne noch mal
wir sind mit einer pandemie konfrontiert
die es so noch nicht in unserer zeit gab
und die natürlich uns alle vor
herausforderungen stellt und es gibt
eben keine blaupausen für für viele der
dinge die wir machen aber ja wir machen
uns gedanken dazu gehört zum einen
natürlich der schutz der wohl haben
da geht es in erster linie darum dass
eben kein infektionserreger in solche
heime pflegeheime krankenhäuser
eingetragen wird das ist das sind geht
zum zugangsberechtigungen da geht es um
umgang mit den betreuern pflegern dem
medizinischen fachpersonal und auf der
anderen seite geht es auch darum
bestimmte test strategien zu entwickeln
also wie test dich am besten wie kriege
ich einen eindruck davon
wie die situation gerade unter den
betreuern und dem personal ist also es
gibt verschiedene konzepte die
erarbeitet werden die sind aber noch
nicht finalisiert und ich sage es auch
gerne sind wirklich auch immer prozesse
die kontinuierlich angepasst sind da
sind wir ziemlich agil und wir passen
uns immer den neuesten
wissenschaftlichen ergebnissen auch
andere
vielen dank die welt erobert
gut
mann ist verschollen
der focus meyer ja wenn man danke dass
sie mich daran nehmen noch eine
ergänzende frage zu der dunkelziffer es
gibt ja schätzungen von verschiedenen
wissenschaftlern liebe sein das ist eine
durchsage start in deutschland von
zwischen 4 und 15 prozent gibt haben sie
eine fundierte schätzung herr professor
wiler dann würde mich auch interessieren
gestern haben ja drei länder lockerungen
der restriktionen angekündigt design
grund anzunehmen dass tschechien
dänemark und österreich eventuell mehr
grund haben die restriktionen zu lockern
also ist dort die entwicklung besser
also ich kann natürlich in keinster
weise etwas dazu sagen wie andere länder
auf ihre maßnahmen reagieren und wie sie
mit ihren eigenen zahlen umgehen ich
möchte zunächst noch mal wirklich sehr
deutlich machen dass wir in deutschland
haben mit der bisher durchgeführten
strategie sehr erfolgreich sind ja wir
haben immer noch genügend beatmungs
plätze werden immer noch genügend
intensivbetten also insofern ist das ja
auch ein rahmen den mann beschreiben
muss und das ist nicht nur die reine
krankheitslast über die wir ja viel
sprechen durch krankheits meldungen
durch krankheit aufenthalt kann
aufenthalt in krankenhäusern und so
weiter sondern es ist ja auch die
kapazität in den einzelnen ländern wie
groß sind die kapazitäten im
gesundheitssystem und und es gibt eine
reihe unterschiede wie menschen leben ob
sie sehr vereinzelt leben oder ob wie
viele in in heimen zum beispiel im und
das heißt also darüber möchte ich mich
wirklich nicht äußern
die frage nach der dunkelziffer die kann
ich ihnen nicht nicht wirklich
beantworten warum weil das eben alles
schätzungen sind solange wir nicht
informationen darüber haben wie der
status der bevölkerung und da müssen wir
eben wirklich studien gerade mit
antikörpern abwarten so lange werden sie
in der presse eine reihe von
verschiedenen zahlen sehen die alle auf
verschiedenen annahmen beruhen die
ergebnisse dieser berechnung sind dann
immer korrekt aber die frage ist welche
annahmen sie dem zugrunde liegen und wir
haben eben wir sind nicht in der lage
wirklich hundertprozentig war leader
annahme zurzeit zu rate zu ziehen die
uns eine gute schätzung ermöglichen
das ist alles was ich dazu sagen kann
und sie sehen an den zahlen die sie
selber nennen
wie stark die schranken und das ist
natürlich schwer für uns mit diesen
zahlen wirklich eine objektive schätzung
anzugeben
vielen dank ich probiere es noch mal bei
der welt herr räubert gott waren versuch
wert dann ndr wdr hackl frühen morgen
das bezieht sich auf die letzte frage
auch so es gibt ja diese schätzung des
imperial college
das in deutschland ende märz bereits
ungefähr 600.000 menschen infiziert
warum also zehnmal so viele als amerika
gemeldet da wollte ich sie fragen wie
sie diese schätzung bewerten welche
auswirkung das dann auf die kreisstelle
trade hat und ergänzend dazu gestern
haben ja mehrere ehemalige mitglieder
des sachverständigenrats für das
gesundheitswesen kritisiert dass die von
ihnen übermittelte case für telegate das
problem derzeit überschätze die bewerten
sie das
also wir haben natürlich sehr viel
erfahrung mit den übersetzungen unter
schätzungen
wir haben bei wir haben dinge auch schon
im zusammenhang mit anderen krankheiten
modelliert also mit zehnfache
unterschätzung ist ist eine zahl die
nicht unrealistisch ist ja aber wie
gesagt dass es ein neues krankheitsbild
wie hat sich das meldeverhalten geändert
die haben wir fahren wir sehr viele
tests sowie das nicht eigentlich bei
anderen kranken der fall ist darum will
ich nicht näher kommentieren aber ist
durchaus eine realistische größe sage
ich mal
die zweite das zweite was sie sagen das
ist ein vorwurf den den ich auch schon
gehört hatte ich glaube da habe ich mich
auch schon freitag zu geäußert ich gehe
eigentlich eher davon aus dass wir es
unterschätzen aber ich möchte noch mal
folgendes sagen
also wir berechnen ja ganz simpel die
zahl der gemeldeten der offiziell
amtlich gemeldeten und darunter die zahl
der verstorbenen das ist ja das ist ja
einfach nur ein einfacher dreisatz den
kann er jeder zu hause nach
rechnen das heißt die zahlen sind
stimmig aber sie beruhen ausschließlich
auf den meldezahlen wir gehen eigentlich
davon aus und das hängt auch damit
zusammen was sie in anderen ländern
sehen dass wir eher mehr fälle haben an
kuwait 19 das ist auch eine einschätzung
die wir treffen weil wir ja viel
erfahrung haben mit anderen krankheiten
die bei uns gemeldet werden aber das ist
eben nicht eine letalität das ist ganz
wichtig die letalität also die zahl
derjenigen die wirklich verstorben sein
wird die werden wir in einigen monaten
wirklich nach berechnen können und dann
können wir uns überall das unterhalten
aber nochmal der entscheidende punkt und
da ist es mir und ich jetzt gar nicht so
wichtig also das war noch eine zahl in
der hand haben der entscheidende punkt
ist dass wir genügend betten im
krankenhaus system haben und die
epidemie so stark verlangsamen können
dass wir alle menschen noch behandeln
können und das ist ein entscheidender
parameter und den schauen wir uns ja
täglich an durch dieses register und uns
dann möchte ich noch mal alle
krankenhäuser aufrufen dass ich wirklich
diesem register auch anmeldet ist eine
freiwillige meldung nach wie vor
damit war wirklich die kapazitäten sehen
denn wir brauchen eine menge von
indikatoren wenn dann seriell wir diese
maßnahmen vielleicht aufheben um zu
sehen wie viel fälle wir haben werden
als ist ja auch klar das möchte ich auch
noch mal deutlich machen eine pandemie
heißt wir haben eine bevölkerung die
keine immunität hat eine pandemie heißt
das etwa 60 bis 70 prozent der
bevölkerung im laufe von vielen monaten
infiziert werden
und das heißt diese daten diese daten
die wir in krankenhäusern sehen schwere
fälle
das ist eine ganz entscheidende
grundlage neben vielen anderen diese
zahlen spielen so eine große rolle nicht
um die krankheit schwere zu
einzuschätzen die sind momentane
aufnahmen und die ändern sich auch jeden
tag vielen dank planet
interview nein jakob ohren hören sie
mich genau genau das knüpft auch noch in
die vorherige frage an also in hamburg
untersuchen dann ja rechtsmediziner
verstorbene daraufhin ob sie nun durch
oder mit dem corona virus gestorben sind
halten sie denn jetzt für die
verstorbenen statistik und auch von
journalisten diese unterscheidung durch
oder mit corona gestorben für sinnvoll
also sollte man da irgendwie dann
auftritten oder ist das duell nicht
notwendig ja vielleicht können sie das
mal sagen ja wie gesagt ich muss noch
mal sagen das ist auch ein akademischer
streit in kinderhaus seit jahrzehnten
es ist oft so bei verstorbenen die an
infektionskrankheiten verstorben sind
zum beispiel ist es oft so dass sie dann
im optionsmodell das virus in dem fall
also dass das infektions gar nicht mehr
nachweisen können und es wird ja doch
noch oft gestritten darüber ob sie an
der an einer sepsis verstorben sind zb
oder eine direkte folge des virus ich
verstehe diese diskussion ich finde sie
auch akademisch sehr sehr wichtig und
ich kann nur sagen dass das jede gruppe
bestimmte annahmen hat und das ist in
dem fall wirklich für die bewertung für
für unsere infektions dynamik nicht von
so hoher bewertung wir sehen inzwischen
was was für mich wichtig ist an den
obduktionen was sind also woran sind die
menschen verstorben wir haben ja
bezüglich cupid 19 noch gar nicht so
viel wissen wir wissen noch gar nicht
woran zum beispiel jüngere menschen
sterben ist es ausschließlich ein
immunsystem das zum beispiel
überreagiert oder was in letzter zeit
immer häufiger auch genannt wird sind
herzmuskelentzündungen und damit also
rhythmusstörungen die teilweise zum tod
der patienten führen
da ist es natürlich nicht immer einfach
festzustellen was jetzt genau das
auslösende agents war aber das sind
daten die dann auf dauer epidemiologisch
erfasst werden wir werden nach dieser
krise nach dieser epidemie sehr sehr
viel genauer sagen können was
mit 19 was dieses dieses virus das saas
kauf 2 virus wirklich initiiert hat und
wo die reaktion des körpers zum tode
beigetragen
das sind daten die verbrauchen darum ist
sehr wichtig dass der obduktion
durchgeführt werden noch eine nachfrage
oder nein danke dass das was in bayern
reporter markus röder
schönen guten morgen werden sie mich
nicht darum die uni erlangen hat ja die
herstellung vorgestoßen zugang erhalten
die urteilen die diese wirkung und
heilung sein könnte der durchbruch sein
plasma es geht um plasmon du kannst
können sie die fragen haben netterweise
noch mal wiederholen die gebärden der
ich kann sie wiederholen ich konnte also
sie haben gesagt die universität
erlangen hat plasma als therapeutikum
eingebracht und was ich davon halten
also ganz ehrlich halte ich das für eine
der lohnenswerten ansätze es gibt ja
viele studien dazu dass rekonvaleszenten
serien oder plasma tatsächlich helfen
kann
allerdings muss das natürlich eine hohe
qualität haben das rad ja auch kann ja
auch bestimmte nebenwirkungen haben aber
den ansatz selber halte ich auf jeden
fall für vielversprechend und es wäre
wunderbar wenn der auch therapeutisch
genutzt wird mit allen einschränkungen
die das für die sicherheit auch bedeutet
geht es darum neben reaktionen
immunologische reaktion aber der ansatz
selber den halte ich für sehr
vielversprechend
wie hoch ist denn im moment die
auslastung der intensivbetten in
deutschland und gehen sie davon aus dass
die momentan kapazitäten ausreichen
ja ich kann ihnen leider nicht sagen ich
weiß nicht ob sie auf die website heute
geschaut haben die ist die zugriffe sind
so stark gewesen dass die website
erstmal technisch überarbeitet werden
muss dann kann
die zahl nicht genau sagen tut mir leid
ich habe echt heute morgen noch mal rum
telefoniert aber wir warten jetzt bis
die wieder hochgeladen ist mit einer
neuen technischen umgebung zurzeit
reichen die kapazitäten aber ich sage es
nochmal ich möchte ich kann hier keine
prognose abgeben ich hoffe natürlich
dass sie ausreichen aber ich bin mir
nicht sicher wir werden es sehen und ich
bin froh über jedes bett und über jeden
beatmungs platz den wir in deutschland
haben denn jeder dieser plätze wird
menschenleben retten und das ist erst
mal wichtig und darum bin ich froh dass
viele krankenhäuser
diese kapazitäten hochgefahren haben und
die höher sie sind desto mehr menschen
leben werden wir retten das ist die
einschätzung die ich habe und wir hoffen
dass sie ausreichen eine eine kurze
nachfrage gibt es auch die möglichkeit
patienten innerhalb deutschlands zu
verlagern
klar dass eines der ziele also eines der
ziele dieses registers ist natürlich
dass man gezielt dann wenn zum beispiel
eine bestimmte das krankenhaus sozusagen
in allem wetten belegt sind dann soll ja
gerade ein patient gezielt zu einem
krankenhaus zu einem anderen krankenhaus
zugeführt werden dass eines der
wichtigen gründe warum wir dieses
register zusammen mit den beiden anderen
gesellschaften aufgebaut haben das ist
ein ganz wichtiger aspekt die frau
berheide und wenn sie netterweise noch
sagen dass redaktion sie vertreten
ja das deutsche ärzteblatt rebecca
beerheide herzlichen dank meine frage
geht an die app die sie vorhin
vorgestellt haben ja professor wieder
dazu zwei fragen wie viele leute müssten
damit machen also ihre daten spenden
damit sie aussagekräftige daten bekommen
das ist das ein und das zweite ist wann
rechnen sie damit dass sie soweit sind
dass sie diese karte dann auch zur
verfügung stellen können
ja da habe ich mir jetzt heute einen der
hellen köpfe des robert-koch-instituts
mitgebracht der ihnen die antwort
übermitteln wird professor brockmann
einer unserer mitarbeiter hören sie mich
ja gut also die frage war nach der
stichprobe wie groß die stichprobe sein
muss wir hoffen dass wir zehn prozent
aller nutzer erreichen ein prozent wäre
schon
supergut wir haben etwa zehn millionen
nutzer von solchen geräten in
deutschland wenn wir 100 tausend aber
auch schon 10.000 menschen erreichen
wäre das klasse für den erkenntnisgewinn
vielen dank mann
wir haben noch vom handelsblatt die frau
will man eigentlich gilt die regel pro
redaktion eine ein vertreter aber wir
haben noch etwas zeit deswegen können
wir von gilt man jetzt bitten die frage
zu stellen als lieben dank für die
ausnahme denn er will er können sie noch
mal erklären wie sie überhaupt eher 0
berechnen woher wissen sie wie viele
andere ein infizierter ansteckt oder
sind das modell rechnungen nun klar sind
dass modellrechnung jetzt muss ich aber
sagen ich weiß nicht wie die experten
noch mal belangen kann können sie
erklären wie wir er 0 berechnen da gibt
es verschiedene wege es gibt
verschiedene mathematische formeln ich
kann es ihnen nur im prinzip erklären
aber natürlich sind es modelle sie
können er 0 das waren nur berechnen in
einem ausbruch der quasi durchläuft aber
auch hier bin ich froh dass ich ein
brockmann an meiner seite habe heute
also zum berechnen von null gibt es
verschiedene ansätze es gibt
statistische modelle die versuchen aus
den meldezahlen also aus den kurven
verläufen aus der dynamik 0 abzulesen
dass wird im wesentlichen so gemacht man
legt ein exponentielles wachstum
zugrunde und schaut sich dann an wie die
abweichung von diesem wachstum sich
darstellen und daraus kann dann er 0
berechnet werden das ist ein ansatz
andere modelle sind eher dynamischer
natur das heißt die basieren auf
mechanistischen modellen in die alle
möglichen faktoren einfließen und aus
denen wird das aus dem verlauf der
epidemie wird dann auch dieser wert
geschätzt ganz wichtig ist dabei dass
man immer alle daten in der
vergangenheit sozusagen den gesamten
kurvenverlauf mit einberechnet deshalb
ist auch ganz wichtig dass die zahlen
die man für heute berechnet auch immer
berücksichtigen was vor einigen tagen
passiert ist ja vielen dank also sind
gut in der zeit dass besteht noch die
möglichkeit die ein oder andere
vorstellen wenn das nicht mehr
erforderlich ist dann bedanken wir uns
ganz herzlich und freuen uns auf den
donnerstag mit ihnen der karfreitag ist
feiertag also ausnahmsweise am
donnerstag diesmal und ja dann freuen
wir uns erstmal dass das system auch
geklappt hat bedanken uns noch mal bei
der technik für die unterstützung und
sehen sie oder hören sie vielmehr am
donnerstag wieder dann einen schönen tag
danke wieder schon